I can't get Bieber's drummer boy out of
my head I blame you don't worry I've got
the cure for everything that ails you at
this point I'm willing to try anything
crank - isn't that the movie about the
guy who has to keep his heart beat over
50 miles an hour the meteor will smash
into the earth uh no that's crank one
and also a bunch of other movies uh
crank 2 is the one where Jason Statham
needs to keep shocking himself with
electricity in order to stay alive
because a bunch of triads stole his
heart that isn't a metaphor is it no
it's not oh I think I'm gonna love this
gran KY voltage is one of the single
most offensive pieces of media ever
created and is an accidental triumph of
avant-garde cinema for the post
videogame audience what you needed more
crank high voltage almost can't be
evaluated on the same terms as other
films because well it's not speaking the
same language the narrative is using an
entirely separate grammar and structure
that only resembles conventional film
because of fundamentals that exist
across all visual media it'd be like
looking at Super Bass and complaining
about how poorly it will perform on the
adult contemporary charts no wait I've
got a better one it's like saying the
Mona Lisa is a bad music video yeah or
the boy in striped pajamas is a bad
how-to guide for world domination dude
not cool oh okay
it uses barely any conventional modern
cinematic structure it doesn't have acts
character arcs or the typical sense of
rising and falling action because it
plays like a video game - the game parts
see video games have an odd convention
that's unique to them and it's that the
narrative progression is typically
contingent on the player's success the
story doesn't advance until the player
defeats the boss collects the star or
racks up enough points the rise and fall
of action from the viewers perspective
is created through game overs and saved
game reloads rather than a character
getting beat down towards the end of the
second act like you would expect to see
in a conventional cinematic story you
have a hard boss fight that leads to the
player dying and reloading a whole bunch
of times this means that when you take a
step back and look at the plot of most
games without the experience of play and
the multiple failures needed to win the
final conflicts make almost no sense the
game becomes a story about the main
villain standing off against a
protagonist who has without failure
blown through hundreds if not thousands
of henchmen and sub bosses often
single-handedly so well your standard
hero arc looks something like this
with things starting bad getting better
than getting worse before shooting way
up at the final confrontation
you get hero arc that is just a straight
upward line this lack of a curve is
becoming less common over time but most
games have to work around this by taking
control away from the player and forcing
them to watch a short movie where the
protagonist is knocked out taken captive
and all their guns are taken away of
course that started off as a way to keep
player character power in check so that
the player wouldn't roll over the second
half of the game with a stockpile of
rockets rather than a concern for
narrative integrity but I digress this
is the exact same arc that we see in
cranked high voltage for serious this
movie plays less like a story and more
like a speedrun of quake Chev Chelios
played by Jason Statham after not dying
from a several hundred foot fall out of
a helicopter has his heart stolen by
triads and replaced with a temporary
mechanical heart when the black market
organ doctors talk about sealing his
penis he decides that he's had enough
murders them and decides to get his
heart back he murders a few hundred
people meet some crazies murders more
people gets knocked out and stripped of
his guns then collects the ultimate
power up and defeat the final boss he
never really fails so much as finds out
that the princess is in another castle
or rather his heart is in another
gangbangers hideout this movie is
aggressive in every definition of the
word it's extremely violent it's laden
with profanity sex and nudity and it's
racist jingoist ablest homophobic
xenophobic Agis sexist anti Authority
and then some I don't think it manages
anti-intellectualism
if only because none of the characters
are smart enough for someone else to
make fun of them and yet for all the
insults and aggression it's not hateful
it doesn't seem to have time for hate
spite or well messages in the Los
Angeles cheff Chelios lives in everyone
is messed up everyone's a sexist racist
violent pig but no one has time to care
due to all the sexing and murdering
they're busy with it's gleefully
oblivious to its own excess
and while it's a terrible movie that's
kind of what makes it amazing it
captures the narrative non arc of a
videogame and does it perfectly in a way
a thousand deconstructive art films
never could by accident it's the stream
of thought film from brains full of
grand theft auto instead of battleship
potemkin
there is no ironic detachment here no
higher level critique of the medium and
the only question is a non question you
know what be sweet filing getting hit by
a car out of nowhere that'd be [ __ ]
sweet
you